I go hard in the paint with this rap
well when is my turn if I only got eight
seconds of the song I want that to be
the most memorable eight seconds of the
song I'm very passionate man whenever I
I just want you to understand it ask
yourself at all times was the reason
you're doing I'm trying to do us say you
do achieve them he's an American hip hop
recording artist
he's also the CEO of his own label Young
Money Entertainment he is sold over 100
million records worldwide
his Lil Wayne and here is my take on his
top ten rules for success rule number
one is my personal favorite I make sure
to stick around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips also as
he's talking if he says something that
is meaningful to you that has an impact
write it in the comments below and put
quotes around it so that other people
can be inspired as well I go hard in the
paint with this rash real hot
I take it real seriously
I take every single thing I do every
word every letter every sentence every
phrase I recall every chorus every verse
every Bridge every intro every outro
personally
so if you have fan at me
then
know that you get to fool me can I get
my all to my music good day you gotta
stand out you know you understand like I
said you don't want to look uh sounds I
feel like nobody else oh you guys I like
when it's my turn if I only got eight
seconds of the song I want that to be
the most memorable eight seconds of the
song thank God every time they're poor
come on I've always women like 200 they
already know that I am peace why do you
think your music is really sort of
hitting its stride for our very very
hard this game you love to work
we don't approach things like with we
just suppose things that we want to work
and we're going to work hard work pays
off if you work that hard and trying to
get and turns to great and hopefully I'm
the definition that do you think you're
great
i Wayne you know for the last two years
you bless the streets with the
freestyles the collaborations the
features not many MCS would want to do
that I like a lot of people you know
they want to hold out the lyrics it what
spires you to like spit so much in such
a short space of time and I can't help
it a thing can't help it no matter what
I breathe it I live it I get it I mean
like that thing when I think about no
well I think the only way I do best I
could explain this what's your best
thing to do I mean whatever you whatever
your favorite thing you to do it is if
it's to count the numbers on the wall
whatever it is well now whatever that
feeling is you get every single time you
do that or hear that I'll say that
that's the exact same feeling I gave all
this time to learn it book that stage is
something that has to do a creativity
anything I'm doing music does have um
late message to upcoming artists today
just basically people try to make in the
world
to the upcoming artists if you are an
audit
please don't never stop your craft don't
let nothing stop you crash what I mean
by that is example my mom tried to stop
my craft and I still did me well my mom
took my tablet I stopped light and just
kept it up it was like if your artist
then do it everything's gonna come your
way every obstacle you guys that's what
you wanna do that you got to do it and
then at the end of you gonna be like I
went through all that and made it hit
after the hot boys broke up
Wayne's solo career was faltering
convinced that the physical process of
writing was constraining his creativity
the 21 year old MC decided to purge
himself of all of his written material
in one pivotal recording session I said
you know what I don't know I won't be
able to wrap anything I've written again
is to record everything I've written all
that once so therefore I have no more
written material armed with a notebook
filled with all of his unrecorded lyrics
Wayne entered the booth and let loose go
it's pistol flavored gonna sort of
matter on my heart is your bass this is
rabbit diamond I've been talking [ __ ]
baby on some family you can hear the
songs ripping to get its pages ripping
it who's going through all these last
raps and I was the last time you ever
wrote anything down we an emerge from
the booth with 10,000 bars an
uninterrupted 35 minute song that would
mark the end of an era when I stopped
right and I've noticed that everything
was really low I can't speak about
nothing but what's real because I can't
write nothing down that changed way as
an artist you started pouring all his
feelings are everything was on his heart
everything was in his head he just all
put it out re-energized by his new
freestyle approach Wayne released the
Carter in 2004 it would go on to become
a top 5 hit and put to rest any doubt
about the 22 year old MC and the label
he had helped build put on rock out I'm
very passionate man who am i I just want
you to understand ask yourself at all
times the reason you're doing I'm trying
to do is say you do children cuz my
reason for picking up that the top I
want to live guitar sing it so vomit
that was my room
theory I wanna buy a good news right now
I want to be able to pick up at the top
sing longer it just turned out to be
something else
I brought a rock album it went gold I
bet your girlfriend know how to say prom
queen I bet you know we drop the world
is nice from off my rock out it worked
I do compassion I want you to understand
if you don't try to do something so I
already tell you know go out there pick
up your top I'm not tough you don't go
out there switch your style I like that
you don't go out there try to make a new
song where you sing it what's up you
don't do that cuz it might work for you
cuz I did it and it worked for me and I
wasn't the first to do it but it worked
for me and now everybody else is trying
to do it working for everybody it's okay
just remember why you did it
I think you I think originality period
could crack not only the UK anywhere
written ality is people people people
straight away from that every time
people do music or anything they do now
they do it like someone who has done it
before or they do it like what they
everything to want I don't do that
I do it I do what I know it is nice to
me why I do what I think is cool and if
you don't think is cool then I think
you're not cool so if you approach you
with that attitude and I think you can
lose now you've got you're working crazy
I mean I've seen you do four videos
today and I only saw four and I'm
exhausted
how big is who I was falling asleep with
the back man
it won't make it
I mean anyway
do it right now determination you set a
goal and I'm one of those people that
actually don't stop until the goal is
done hmm yeah so I set that goal at the
finishing Wayne says he started writing
songs as a child growing up in New
Orleans living in one of the poorest
wards and wellness realities handed to
you
very very early that's the difference
between the ones and everywhere else
yeah AD after Katrina hit Lane
remembered where he came from
donating two hundred thousand dollars to
rebuild a neighborhood park where he
played as a kid the work day in the werk
whatever is used the song you're singing
at the Grammys
is about Katrina right
and that song you write I knew some
people who
we're in that pool right
are you still angry about it
angry isn't the word how do you feel
about playing that song at the Grammys
I can't wait it's been like this his
whole life Wayne expressing himself
through his music
oh well always Oh
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Janet or
Jeanette Sedano
asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next and leave it down the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I also
love to know which of the top ten rules
have the biggest impact on you and why
what change you're going to make in your
business or life after watching this
video leave in the comments I will join
in the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Justin Morgan from
new future builder comm Justin thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
really really really means a lot to me
those you watching you want your chance
at a shadow in the future video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
where it is and I'll see you soon
where did you get the name little Wayne
and by the way do I call you Wayne
wheezy lil Chloe Wayne is fine
Wayne is so perfect but you're really
waning right your name so why'd you drop
the D I'll tell you right here on TV I'd
love to D because I'm a junior and my
father's living and he's not in my life
and he's never been in life so I don't
want to be annoying
I'd rather be waiting does he know that
he knows now is that an interview that
you actually gave with Katie Couric is
that an interview that I actually gave a
cake um yeah
pushing having it hey well then that's
not the question like the one I read
once Oh Pete Ross Steve Rogers that's a
stupid ass question you just saw me are
they giving it interview with her okay
so that was you isn't it something that
you would remember if your album the
Carter three was the biggest selling
album of the year in 2008 isn't it
something that I would remember that yes
isn't that a personal opinion type
question that's how I got that I mean
because I would be actually answering
the question - isn't it something that's
my question isn't it's something that
you would remember isn't it something
that's the question I have to answer you
know Jordan it's something you get to do
the best try to answer it yes something
that is that's - yeah yeah it is
something I don't your ass if you ever
hired a photographer to photograph an
event and I have hired a photographer to
photograph Cyrus I know I'm a superstar
people hire them this house to
photograph me we don't hire them how
would you describe your image in the
media how would I describe my image in
the media yes I wouldn't describe it
well how would you describe it if you
had to I don't have to
well what image are you portraying in
the media
I don't betray anything I am Who I am
and you guys put right with you you know
who are you who is the real and Elaine
Michael caught a junior Jay do you would
like to portray yourself as I just asked
at that and said that I don't like to
portray myself as nobody okay exactly
we'll just be doing Michael Carter jr. I
don't portray myself as anything an
image is self described well you have to
wait till I'm done with the quest I
don't have to wait to anything honestly
I I mean this guy right here may tell me
that I have to wait but personally I
don't have to do that
Oh me how did you guys connect could you
all her friends that he's been a big
influence on you know Lil Wayne and I
are like no I know that's a dog yes
that's my dog yeah
he kept saying to me I'm a gangsta miss
I remember I remember the interview I
watched it was great but how did you
guys get to know each other um we were
introduced through another gentleman
from Houston his name is jazz Prince he
um he found me on MySpace and loved my
music on MySpace and uh he was like man
I know little Wayne and i'ma play him
your music one day and I was just like
yeah right you know like you didn't ever
really I didn't buy it at first and then
um and I'll never forget you know one
day I was getting we started you know we
formed a relationship and we used to
talk and chop it up and chop it up is
like you know converse thank you like a
figured that but thanks for the tree
okay thank you
um and so yeah we would talk and he
called me one day and I was in the
barber shop getting my hair cut and he
was like and and but it still you know
he called me from his number but you
know I was like in the phone rang I
picked it up and there's a cow and I was
like you probably know that voice I was
like I was like hello as I yell was that
I was like this doesn't sound like my
friend and he's that yellow SAP is lazy
and it was you know it ended up being it
ended up being Wayne and he was like I'm
starting this thing called young money
and I'd really love for you to be a part
of it so I want to fly you out to
Houston and meet you and uh and he did
just that the day after and that formed
our relationship and I was like this
quiet kid in the corner of the bus yeah
while everything was going on around me
and the Carter three was just I think it
was like maybe two or three weeks away
from coming out and what a time yeah
what about what what kind of advice did
he give you or how did he help you kind
of take your music to the next step the
greatest advice Wayne has ever given me
and it's a constant it's it's less of
advice and more of a constant reminder
which I love him so much for saying this
to me is you know he's always just like
man please be yourself please don't ever
or try and be me or anybody else don't
ever go get tattoos you don't have to do
you don't have to dress any different
you know because I like from the day MIT
Wayne met me to now I didn't I haven't
changed anything about myself he met me
and he really liked the kid that he met
you know he's I don't know how old were
you drinking oh that was about I'd say
it was like two years yeah two or three
when that album came yeah yeah years ago
so um and he was like don't stop smiling
either don't try and get mean or
aggressive he's I just be you man just
be you and rap about life and women and
family and just love life and be happy
be that guy be the guy that I could
never be because he can't be that guy
because he has tattoos all over his face
then he has dreads and he has diamonds
in his mouth and he's a completely
different person